Trey,
my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
It's like one one 35 first opened up.
It was in the UFC.
It was,
there wasn't as many guys that were that elite like even to watch the guys who
are really good improve.
Like you saw the Cody fight where he was fucking fantastic against Dominick help
God damn good to teach a look against Linacre completely.
No five Linacre nullified them.
We were going to Kurt,
he's like one of the best examples of a guy with absolutely freakish physical
attributes of fucking iron jaw,
iron Joe.
I'd never even seen the guy get hurt.
He gets hit by everybody,
gets head kicked,
he gets punched.
Rob Font said he hit him with the hardest punch.
He ever hit anybody with his life and he goes,
he didn't even acknowledge that he hit him.
He just walked right forties and he hit him with a body shot.
Felt like he got hit by a car.
He didn't look like this,
that Linacre.
I don't think that same Linacre showed up on Saturday or Friday and teaching all
fight them.
He didn't have any days,
but [inaudible] was very hesitant and I think it was because of tjs,
the way he was fighting and with a faints,
the takedowns,
the kicks and throwing that that head kick to the body kick.
But he was very tentative.
He got,
he got out beat,
you throw him in the truck,
almost had them in a cab.
I thought he was going to go for the twister and I was like,
oh my God,
if he goes to the twister,
but he got went to the capsulize it,
but I'm like,
I looked it up.
Like he's not going to tap to that.
It's just paying a stump.
He needed a stump down looked amazing.
Amazing.
Yeah.
And the timing and those takedowns like lightening bolts.
Like it looks like he's throwing a punch and he's underneath you.
Just,
it was so nice.
He's so fast,
man.
But God damn Cody Garbrandt what the fuck?
God Damn.
I'll admit I,
I said I think code is going to be champ.
Just not just,
not yet.
He's gonna be your champ,
but he's not ready for dom yet.
No opening round.
I was like,
what the fuck?
He's so busy mimic him.
He's doing break dancing.
He's doing push ups and shit.
He fucked with Dominic's head.
And that was what one of the things I was thinking,
I was like,
this kid's been in a lot of street fights.
Like I don't know if there's trash talk is going to work on him.
The way it works on other guys.
Like he said he was fine in there.
Like I asked him,
but he's like,
I liked that.
It goes,
I feel calm.
He goes,
I know I can stay calm when that's going on.
And,
and I think he's just like this young hungry dude who,
he took it personal and a lot of guys get real emotional.
And I was worried that Cody come out super emotional and just get merch like
taken down.
Just,
you know,
the real emotional like,
uh,
all the dude against me,
Gregor,
we just forget that I was technique and rushes and gets marked.
But dude,
he just took all that and the best performance.
I mean,
can you name another performance like that where the guy,
he remembered,
he was even number one contenders,
five or six in the world.
He was eight.
Was he a,
I thought I moved to six maybe,
but that might have been some shenanigans.
Just a who knows the cheeto finger rankings.
Yeah,
but still motherfucker went from five,
six rank number one.
I'm the one that's a big stretch.
Handily.
It wasn't a dumb one.
One round.
Yeah.
And I love on me one one or I'm Cody dropped him,
hurt him.
We,
we don't,
we still don't exactly know where the cut came from.
Some people were saying he came from a punch.
Hear people online say came from a kick.
The Guy,
definitely not.
But the guys in the trucks that it was ahead by your truck boys were off.
Cause I heard when they said that,
I'm like,
what the fuck are they watching?
Yeah,
they,
they uh,
pulled it up for me,
but it's hard.
See,
while the fights going on,
they'll do that.
And I'll tell me it's a head bud and see,
I have two monitors in front of me.
I have one right here and then have one over the side and they'll say like look
on monitor be and then they'll show it to me but I can't really,
it's hard for me to do that while I'm watching the actual fight,
you know?
So they'll show it to me and I usually,
I just take their word for it but occasionally it gets too,
but I'm talking in the replay that they showed maybe they saw different and
didn't show the correct one to replay that they showed it was definitely wasn't
the head but well they definitely did collide heads for sure.
For sure.
And so who knows?
It was hard to tell,
but who gives a fuck either.
It was a big ass cut,
big ass cut on Dom's eyebrow and he got drunk.
How good is Dominick?
Cruz took a punch too,
but he gets in,
he gets cracked,
his legs go stiff.
He goes down and a couple of times Cody like acted almost like he wasn't going
to follow him to the ground and beat on him on the ground and almost acted like
he was done.
He was like calling him up or like a Mark Hunt kind of walk off Caleb better get
on and say did he do,
didn't even make an attempt.
Right.
Well maybe he doesn't want to have anything to do with the ground.
Maybe feels like that's where Dominic might have a chance to shush it down
there.
I don't know what Dominick Cruz wanting to punish him to.
Maybe just Dominick Cruz have any submissions.
Oh No.
Dominick Cruz is really good on the ground.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
I mean on his record.
Does he have any submissions?
Yeah,
he has some missions usually from guillotines though back in the day.
Does he see his Jujitsu is really good.
Trust me.
No,
no,
no.
You can't do with them.
He's a black belt for sure.
I've seen him compete and introduce the tournaments.
Yeah.
And uh,
and he wrestled as well.
He's a wrestler,
but for a guy not to go down in his guard,
that's some shit.
That's like some Conor Mcgregor,
Dia Shit.
We were like,
ah,
I just don't want,
I,
I can lose two easily down there.
Well,
I mean it might not have been that at all.
It might have been even more simple.
That's a lost Jamie
naked.
Yeah.
So he's got a rear naked there.
He's got,
so he lost to a,
he's got one room naked Joe.
You're right.
Well who knows.
So we do.
You still,
you don't know what he could do.
But the bottom line was Cody wanted to keep the fight standing.
He just wanted to punish him.
Getting hit him so hard.
It might've thought the fight was over.
He,
he seemed to be the answer for Dominic.
I mean at least it worked for Cody.
Was it?
Or was it not?
I'm no Stryker that he made Dominic come to him.
And it's different when,
correct.
Is that what it was?
Well,
sort of,
but it's also,
you got to give credit to his teams.
He,
Justin Buchholz and those guys had been imitating.
They fought dom so many times,
six,
nine.
You can imitate his movements so they can mimic his shit.
So when they're sparring,
they do that,
that fake stuff that like false start.
You know,
cause dom does this thing where he false starts and then he'd start and you
never know which one's going to be a kick,
which is a lot of like,
like patterns at dom throws up.
So they figured out how to do that and they mimicked and they watched him so
many times that they can get it down to a,
and Cody didn't buy into the fates.
You're just like,
come on if you're going to come on,
come in within this range.
And he kept baiting him and [inaudible] and they'd make account.
Yeah.
The bottom line is if his brain's not confused and he just knows that in these
exchanges,
Dom's going to be there and he's going to do some,
you know,
he's got some really unpredictable movement.
Dom does,
but he does like a bunch of things a lot.
And then commit.
Yeah.
And so he timed those things and Cottonwood,
some fucking vicious punches,
man.
Yeah.
And a,
yeah,
he wasn't,
you'll like dom fight Talala guys.
And they're like,
what duff fuck?
It's like that Chris Ducker,
maybe we get to in the face of guy,
which one y'all kicked me and you don't know where it's coming from,
but can you just,
uh,
he just Garbrandt just never bought it.
Like I'm just gonna wait for you to commit.
You can do all that jazz and I'm just going to wait right here.
It's also a guy's been boxing when he was real young when you were talking about
last night.
Yeah.
It was eight 32 and two amateur record.
You look at that,
but in the UFC compared to other fighters,
that boxing comes in handy.
Huge.
He was coaching,
he was,
Cody was catching Dominick Cruz on the way out.
[inaudible] which that's a lot of people don't catch him on the way and never
see it.
No,
he was catching them on the way up and the speed and precision of his punching
power.
Glorious for five rounds.
And then people forget Cody in high school.
He,
I think he was first team all state out of Ohio,
which is big deal out there.
He had scholarships,
Played Division One,
or I'm sorry,
compete in division one wrestling.
It was like,
Nah,
I'm just going to fight professionally and full time.
That's what kind of stud you're dealing with.
And his uncle was an alternate for the Olympic boxing team,
so I mean,
he comes from a long line of just savages do pretty crazy.
Yeah.
This,
his countdown piece was pretty amazing.
[inaudible].